yeah so three major components during
the pandemic
number one is we needed to make sure
that students had devices
and connectivity we had tens of
thousands of students across our state
that did not have devices and
connectivity
that has been taken care of and if if
you know anyone if a family says they
don't have then please make sure they
reach out to their school because we
worked very hard
we're the only state in the nation that
we can say that every single child that
was learning at a distance has a device
and has connectivity
the next thing is that our teachers have
the support that they need
to teach at a distance they were thrown
into it just like the kids and the
family so all the construct of people
and support and then lastly is high
quality content
making sure that the materials that the
teachers had and the students had was of
high quality
so those were the things at the state
level that we
focused on we had digital engineers told
people to get battle born buddies
to make sure that the learning goes
forward in a positive way